>> Hi everybody. I'm Claire Johnson and I
know some of you [laughs] and I work in online
sales, in the sales organization, and I'm
very excited to introduce one of our "Authors
@ Google" speakers because she is a friend
of mine and Amy and I went to business school
together now a long time ago [laughs] which
is like shocking to me now and I will say
that one of the things that you - if you've
heard anything about her book or read the
bio in the announcements about this talk is
Amy is true to her background which is highly
creative, versatile person who proves that
an MBA is not a death sentence on your creativity
or your ability to think across functions
and what I would say is if you think about
what she's done before business school working
in museums and then after working both in
very unique finance companies as well as getting
an art degree in - I think in painting as
well as doing some work again but more on
the strategy for the tape in London, I think
you'll see that she shows sort of a proof
that you can move around and probably add
a lot of value because you're breaking down
a silo across organizations. And one of the
things that I think we try to do at Google,
and I think largely we're successful but sometimes
we're not, is to think beyond our current
place, whether that's with a product or when
we think about innovation and how we reach
our advertisers in a lot of dimensions. So
I think what Amy is going to do today is talk
-- give a little bit of a talk that she has
tailored for this Google audience and also
then read from "Museum Legs" which is her
latest project in addition to some other side
projects that she was filling me in on last
night and I would just say there are people
you'll meet in your life who make you think
differently and ask you questions that make
you reconsider sort of your world view and
Amy is one of them and I hope – and I imagine
she will do that for all of you today so with
that, Amy Whitaker, author of "Museum Legs".
[applause]
Amy Whitaker: Thanks so much for being here.
Thanks Pepe and everyone else for hosting
me and thanks Claire for the kind introduction.
I would say likewise when you -- if you decide
to go business school, you show up, and there
are people there and you think, 'Wow, do I
get to business school with people like this?',
and
Claire is definitely that person so - I am
going to talk a little bit about a book called
"Museum Legs" and I'm going to start by giving
a little bit of background on why I wrote
the book and contextualizing it in a larger
concept of art and creativity. If, if at any
point I'm hard to hear, just raise a hand
please and I'll speak up. So I started writing
this book many, many millions of years ago,
just out of business school when I noticed
two different things happening at the same
time. One is that this is around 2001 and
museums were expanding architecturally at
record rates and they also had record breaking
numbers of visitors. At one point in time,
there were 52 pending expansion projects in
the United States alone that would have added
4 million square feet of exhibition space
at a combined cost of 4 billion dollars which
is I think double the operating budget of
the two hundred largest museums in the United
States. So I was noticing this at the same
time. Every time I took my friends to museums
they looked a little bit more like this so
this is a classic case of numbers or success
metrics on the one hand and stories or experiential
knowledge on the other and I wanted to be
able to reconcile these things and the first
thing I learned is that museum fatigue is
not a new concept at all. There's a wonderful
man named Benjamin Ives Gilman who wrote a
book in 1918 called "Museum Ideals of Purpose
and Method" and he devoted an entire chapter
to seats as preventatives of fatigue, these
wicker stools he thought everyone should carry
around. These are images illustrating the
fact that artwork is often hung at the wrong
height. He made an observation that still
holds true that museums are one of the only
areas of modern life where you are asked to
stand to concentrate and to sit to rest. Offices,
cinemas, theaters are all different from that.
And the question remains how would you design
a museum that has original works of arts where
people could actually sit in front of them
and you could have more than five people in
a gallery at the same time. If you know an
answer to that, let me know. I haven't figured
it out myself. So I decided, given this conundrum,
that I would write not for the policy architects
of museums but for people who go to them.
I thought that the fact my friends were getting
bored and tired in museums might be a marker
of what is essentially political disenfranchisement,
this idea of feeling a little bit left out
of the
conversation around, especially contemporary
art. So the book took this form as academically
researched. I was lucky to have a Harvard
library card at the time I started but also
written in this more anecdotal personal format.
So skepticism toward modern art is nothing
new, it's been around as long as modern art
has been in the United States. It made its
debut in what's called "The Armory Show" in
1913 when a bunch of people who'd seen groundbreaking
modern work in Europe decided to bring it
to New York. This is what the installation
of the show looked like and it was so controversial
at the time that Theodore Roosevelt, among
others, took the time to write about it and
I just want to read a quick passage of what
Theodore Roosevelt wrote.
[pause]
He, as you might imagine, is a very gracious
man so he thanked the organizers profusely
and then went on to say that "the lunatic
fringe was fully in evidence. The Cubists
are entitled to the serious attention of all
who find enjoyment in the colored puzzle pictures
of the Sunday newspapers. There is no reason
why people should not call themselves Cubists
or Octagonists or Knights of the Isosceles
Triangle or Brothers of the Cosine, if they
so desire; as expressing anything serious
or permanent, one term is as fatuous as another."
He went on the compare the now iconic painting
"Nude Descending a Staircase #2" unfavorably
to a Navajo rug in his own bathroom.
"If you wanted to call the rug 'a well dressed
man going up a ladder' the name would in fact
fit the facts just about as well as in the
case of the Cubist picture of the naked man
going downstairs. From the standpoint of terminology,
each name would have whatever merit inheres
in a rather
cheap straining after effect; and from the
standpoint of decorative value, of sincerity,
and of artistic merit, the Navajo rug is infinitely
ahead of the picture." This kind of skepticism
still exists. This is a work by Joseph Boyes
called "Lightning Stag". I have the dubious
distinction of having accidentally seen almost
every version of it in the world. This is
it up close. I have a friend who refers to
it as an Olympic turd and these are people
in the installation; this is "Lightning Stag"
over here. So these are the people that the
book is really for and if you're asking a
question of why museums bore or tire people,
what you're really asking is why that matters.
No one would write or read a whole book about
tiredness by definition and to me it matters
for two other reasons and one is that political
life of museums as institutions and the other
is the widespread presence of creativity as
a basic human attribute. So I like to call
these the first principles of art; visual
thinking, imagination, and creativity. Visual
thinking; we live in one of the most visually
overwhelming cultures of all time. We're constantly
making sense of the built environment. We
even create machines that can read things
like this and machines that can read things
like this. They scan for zip codes and where
they fail, there are people that have crazy
brains that remember all of the zip codes
in the United States and they serve the same
function. This conversely is from a company
that will hand address junk mail so that it
gets
opened so then we're having to decide if this
looks like someone we know sent it or it looks
like a magazine subscription offer. In fact,
almost everything that exists in the world,
with the exception of abstract expressionists
paintings, is drawn before it comes into existence.
This is a Rubik cube. Almost
every patent application has an attached drawing.
This is the 1939 Museum of Modern Art Building.
At MoMA, it's probably one of the great art
projects of the 20th century. It was founded
by three women who met by accident and opened
the doors ten days after the Stock Market
Crash of 1929. Between 1929 and 1939, they
didn't have a permanent home. That's the model
for the building and a lot of people will
say I'm not really an artist, I can't draw,
I can't draw a stick figure. These are, I
think, exquisite stick figures by an artist,
David Shrigley, and if you really think that
you can't draw consider that you have a signature.
So one of the most basic parts about drawing
is that it requires present mindedness of
actually noticing the world around you, of
actually looking at a vase well enough to
draw the specific contour of it and one of
the things that noticing and present mindedness
allows is innovation, essentially imagining
relative to what's there and what's possible
and the example I'm using here of imagination
is a man named Roger Bannister. Some of you
probably know who he is. Roger Bannister was
the first person to run a mile in under four
minutes. At the time he did it, in May of
1954, people thought it was physically impossible
as if a law of nature that you could not run
that fast. He did it with help from his friends
and a lucky day of weather and last minute
encouragement from a coach he happened to
bump into and after he did it, he only held
the record for 45 days before he was beat
by a bunch of other people and now the current
world record in the mile is 3 minutes and
46 seconds so there's this kind of basic notion
of progress, that something seems absolutely
impossible, someone demonstrates it,
and then a lot of people best that effort.
Another example of imagination; this is a
man named George Fairchild. George Fairchild
grew up in a very poor sharecropping family
and reinvented himself a number of times over.
First as a publishing executive and then as
the Chairman of the company that became IBM.
So in 1916, when he was the Chairman of IBM,
the company was first listed on the New York
Stock Exchange. So imagine the feeling of
being at a pinnacle of achievement at that
point and then imagine how much technology
and IBM has changed since then. So imagination
and creativity have this notion of a kind
of point and time at which someone is making
a creative work but a much longer arch of
how that might be interpreted and museums
are often kind of taking the more aerial view
as opposed to the person in the woods starting
at a tree view of creativity where you are
often appreciating something from a great
distance and this is just a reminder that
creativity and imagination are everywhere
and they're a lot messier and unpredictable
then one might think looking at them in hindsight.
As one more example, some of you, I'm sure,
know this man better then I do. This is Whitfield
Diffie. He is the computer scientist who is
largely credited with inventing public and
private key encryption and what I really appreciate
about his story is that Diffie, first of all,
didn't learn to read until he was ten years
old and then it wasn't seen as a big deal.
He plowed through a book and subsequently
learned about ciphers in the 5th grade and
took a great interest in cryptography when
he was an adult. He read a 1,200 page book
called "The Code Breakers" and then spent
1973 driving around the country in a Datsun
510 visiting libraries; this is pre Internet;
to read all the books he could find on encryption.
He ended up in the Stanford campus, had a
half hour meeting that led to a research appointment,
and a PhD application. He had all this training
in what is essentially the craft of computer
science. He'd studied artificial intelligence
but the actual moment of creative breakthrough
came in May of 1975 when he was living in
the house of a professor John McCarthy, also
an artificial intelligence pioneer, acting
as a "house husband" taking care of McCarthy's
daughter so this is how this breakthrough
is described. Diffie's routine at the time
was to fix Mary, his wife, whom he met on
the Datsun drive through breakfast before
she went to work at her job analyzing geologic
findings at British Petroleum. Then he would
spend the rest of the day alternating between
domestic chores and research. Sometime during
that afternoon he altered the course of cryptography
by "splitting the key." So this is Diffie
talking about his experience. "The thing I
remember distinctly is that I was sitting
in the living room when I thought of it the
first time and then I went downstairs to get
a Coke and I almost lost it. I mean, there
was this moment when I was thinking about
something. What was it? And then I got it
back and didn't forget it." So this is the
notion of creativity that I think is so important
and that is what museums are important in
relation to and I just want to - I'm going
to keep showing this to replicate my own experience
of bumping into it in museums all over the
world. So the thing about this work is that
the artist, Joseph Boyes, is the person who
most famously said that everyone is an artist
and that comment can seem a little bit rich
coming from someone who mostly worked in felt
and lard, this piece excepted but I think
that there's a lot of truth in it and I want
to just go through two examples before I read
a passage from the book. So, does anyone know
who this is a picture of?
>> Frank Lloyd Wright.
Amy Whitaker: It's Winston Churchill. He's
a person who liked to smoke a cigar while
painting. So we think of Winston Churchill
as a savior of the free world because of his
role as the Prime Minister and Minister of
Defense during World War II. In 1915, he left
a job as the First Lord of the Admiralty.
He truly thought his career in politics was
over and he took up painting as a hobby.
[pause]
Here he is again, I love the cigar. These
are what his paintings looked like and he
says - he wrote an essay called "Painting
as a Past Time" and I'm just going to read
a short bit starting from here. "I hope this
is modest enough: because there is no subject
on which I feel more humble or yet at the
same time more natural. I do not presume to
explain how to paint, but only how to get
enjoyment. Do not turn the superior eye of
critical passivity upon these efforts. Buy
a paint box and have a try.
[pause]
[background talking]
It would be a sad pity to shuffle or scramble
along through one's playtime with golf and
bridge, pottering, loitering, shifting from
one heel to the other, wondering what on earth
to do - as perhaps is the fate of some unhappy
beings - when all the while, if you only knew,
there is close at hand a wonderful new world
of though and craft, a sunlight garden gleaming
with light." So I think that again, this point
in time of creativity, Churchill had no idea
that his life would probably be his greatest
work of art and that 25 years after he left
this position, he would be called to so much
more governmental duty and I think all of
us probably have the kind of elastic possibility
but it's hard to be reminded of it all the
time. This is Alfred Barr, also a consummate
artist. Alfred Barr happens to be the founding
director of the Museum of Modern Art. He was
chosen when he was 27 years old and they plucked
him out of a teaching job at Wellesley College.
He was recommended by a man named Paul Sachs
who used to teach a legendary connoisseurship
class at Harvard. Paul Sachs happens also
to have been a retired Goldman Sachs partner
who was related to both Goldman and Sachs.
Alfred Barr essentially fashioned an entire
museum from scratch, working closely with
these three women who were the founders. He
modeled the multi-departmental plan after
the syllabus of his own course and he was
so pioneering that in 1943 they stone cold
fired him. They thought he was not being enough
of a scholar when he in fact he was being
a professional manager. Barr had such loyalty
to the institution, he stayed on at half his
salary and a title of Director of Collections.
They much later realized what he had done
and honored him but he basically created an
institution that grew to a public scale and
I'll just give you two quick examples of that.
MoMA has one of the best known photography
departments in the world. The way the photography
department came about, and I say this to people
who work for one of the most creative start
up companies of our generation, there is a
man named Beaumont Newhall who was hired in
as the librarian. Beaumont Newhall wasn't
getting paid very much and so Barr use to
give him extra work taking installation photos
so every time they had an exhibition, he'd
go around and take a picture of the gallery
itself. So they didn't have a darkroom so
Beaumont Newhall used to develop the film
in the men's room of the townhouse where they
were and one day Barr came up to him and said,
"What do you think about trying to host a
photography exhibition?" Long story short,
Beaumont quickly realized he was being tapped
to organize it and then it went well and he
became the founding director of the department.
The second story is that in 1957 or 1958,
the MoMA building actually caught on fire.
I have a picture of this. While members of
the trustees and senior staff were in standard
issue fire brigade helmets, members of the
public were standing across the street and
as a couple of people recalled they would
unsolicitedly walk over and deposit a dollar
or five dollars on the membership desk and
then leave. That kind of public sentiment
toward museums has probably not been engendered
in this country for a long time. So the public
sentiment in this notion of trust in museums
is what this passage I'm about to read is
about so this is a piece from a chapter called
"The Insulated Judiciary" and I'll read several
pages, and then break, and then read a little
bit from the Epilogue of the book. Can I switch
microphones mid stream? Okay. [pause] Can
you all hear me on this?
[talking in background] I'm sorry? Oh. [more
talking in background and laughter] Umm, okay.
There are few things in life that can be counted
upon, but one of them is that, if you are
in a museum standing in front of a work by
Lucio Fontana, someone will probably be standing
next to you saying, “Anyone could paint
that.” Of course, the person is using the
term “paint” loosely. Many of Fontana’s
finest pieces are not exactly painted, per
se. They consist of canvases stretched over
a frame, left raw or coated in a solid color
and then slit with a knife.
[pause]
The canvas spreads and folds back at the slits,
a little like a loaf of bread dough about
to be put in the oven. Fontana’s pieces
are lightning rods, seemingly put there to
collect stray skepticism toward abstract art.
To its credit, Fontana’s work exhibits fastidious
craftsmanship. It is harder than it looks
to slit a canvas that neatly or to paint it
that uniformly. But his work still falls into
a long line of inadvertent rebuttals to the
idea that technical mastery, especially of
a representative nature, is required to make
art. As Ben Lewis, a commentator for the Evening
Standard, once phrased it in a review titled
“A Lesson in Art History from Mrs. Blobby”.
A whole sub-genre of art has appeared which
trades on the fact that it looks as if it
has been tipped out of a rubbish sack while
making important philosophical statements
about the nature of creativity, the myth of
the artist-genius and the act of creation.
In the case of artworks that most elicit a
speechless “What the …?”, why does a
museum choose to own them? And what are the
grounds for the visitor’s confidence in
the museum’s judgment? The viewer's trust
in the museum is the springboard for the museum’s
educational mission. Trust is what makes the
viewer patient. As if in a principle of physics,
the steadier the base, the further the cantilever
can extend, meaning the greater the center
of gravity of trust, the greater the range
of comfort and experimentation with uncomfortably
new art.
[pause]
In the fall of 1997 I took my parents to the
Museum of Modern Art to see On the Edge: Contemporary
Art from the Werner and Elaine Dannheisser
Collection. For purposes of this story, it
is important to characterize my parents as,
above all, patient people, academics in specialized
fields with a Herculean tolerance for things
that take a long time to understand, and indulgent
in experiencing their children’s professional
lives. I had visited the show the day before
with a friend who was installing it and I
had been struck by how majestic the art looked
when all of the cranes and the art handlers
were still around. Messy and real in the Velveteen
Rabbit sense, it was not suffering the false
appearance of ease that a pristine art installation
shares with a world class figure skater or
an extremely well groomed person. The tour
began with two paintings that could best be
described, compositionally, as doodles, the
swirly kind you would make if your Bic pen
were running out of ink, except blown up four
thousand percent. The scribble paintings were
decidedly unexpressive. I was unsure if this
was the point. Equipped with this knowledge,
a term I use loosely, we rounded the corner
past neon signs by Bruce Nauman. These were
at once totally intelligible, words that light
up, and completely foreign; why these words?
Beyond the Nauman, we proceeded past what,
in a horror movie, would be the first, nearly
overlooked sign of impending disaster. It
was a leg sticking out of the wall, about
a foot above the floor. Made of strangely
translucent wax and covered meticulously with
leg hair, it had a shoe and sock on one end
and a trouser leg disappearing into the wall
at the other. The sock and trouser hem framed
that snippet of skin you would see if someone
in a suit was wearing short socks and crossed
his legs. Before I had time to process this
image fully, we wandered into the Jeff Koons
room. I knew Koons’s early work consisting
of vacuum cleaners lit up majestically with
fluorescent tube lights and displayed in the
vacuum seal of perfect Lucite boxes. To pay
for the Hoovers, the artist had famously worked
as a commodities
trader, a job second in iconic status only
to his stint selling memberships at the Museum
of Modern Art. He still claims the record
for having sold the most. He is perhaps better
known for his subsequent work - the gigantic
topiary puppy outside the Guggenheim Bilbao,
his Banality series sculpture of Michael
Jackson and his pet chimpanzee Bubbles, or
the photographs of him and his then wife engaging
in various sex acts against My Pretty Pony,
cotton candy backdrops. I would show obscene
work here but it didn't see merited relative
to the need for the example. The cumulative
effect of doodles, neon signs, and a wax leg
was already overloading our brains and slowing
down our pace when we swiveled around and
there it was, the piece de resistance. We
all stared for a moment. My clinician father,
no stranger to thorough analysis and nimble
intuition, turned to me. Pausing for a moment,
with that nonjudgmental air of a parent surveying
a child's abstract art project, he asked,
in a kind and curious tone, "So Amy, why are
the basketballs floating in the fish tank?"
The short answer was that I had absolutely
no idea. I could see that there were three
of them, that their demi-submersion formed
a kind of composition against the half full
tank. We could see the NBA branding, a few
incongruities, and some evidence of formalism.
Yet we were in exactly that cantilevered moment
of deciding whether to trust the museum, to
call a bluff, or to say “uncle” and end
the mental arm wrestle and adjourn to the
cafe. This was exactly when trust in the museum
mattered, as if that trust were an instruction
from a judge to us as the jury about granting
the museum generosity on the burden of proof.
As in, be compassionate; this work is new
to the museum too. This kind of compassion
is often inversely proportionate to how arrogant
or extortionate or pretentious the voice of
that presentation is. If the museum has spoken
with intellectual empathy, in the spirit of
conversation, I wipe my eyes, resign myself
to the dull headache, and reboot to try, try
again. In this case, abject confusion coincided
with admiration for the curator, and so I
purchased a copy of the exhibition catalogue
on our way out of the museum. As I sat down
with a book and a bracing cup of coffee, I
saw that MoMA’s then chief curator Kirk
Varnedoe’s warm introduction had given us
some retroactive fair warning: “To its great
credit, this collection seems to have nothing
‘easy’ about it.” Rob Storr, the curator
of the exhibition, had written the bulk of
the catalogue, an alphabetized collection
of essays about the artists. It seemed that
the wax leg could have been foreboding after
all. As Storr writes, and I quote, "A work
of art by Robert Gober is a true or false
question for which the only adequate answer
is anxious indecision, since the exquisite
falsehood of the objects that provoke this
response is also the purveyor of basic, disquieting
emotional truths.” Even the title of the
wax leg, Untitled, was disquieting, no mask
for the list of materials: “wax, cotton,
leather, human hair, and wood.” Storr himself
is trained as a painter and is someone I trust
implicitly to elucidate difficult art and
I'll just tell a couple of quick stories summarizing,
some of these are in the text. I had a friend
who was his personal assistant and she bet
me once to get his autograph because he was
doing a program with the artist Chuck Close
and swarms of people were asking for Chuck
Close's autograph and he was just sitting
there by himself and the reason the joke was
funny is that he'd just come off of a red
eye flight and was probably delighted to sit
by himself so I didn't have any paper and
took up a copy of this book I had just bought
called "Teach Yourself Post Modernism", part
of the same series as "Teach Yourself Bridge"
which I also own, and he looked at it and
said, "I didn't write this book." And I said,
"Well, it's a guide to postmodernism. It would
be appropriate if you signed it." And he signed
it Pierre Menard aka Robert Storr which is
a reference to a Borges story about an author
whose work coincides word for word with a
whole section of "Don Quixote" by Cervantes.
I don't know anyone who makes pithy Borges
references when jet lagged, apart from Rob
Storr. He also, I think, loves art enough
that you'll see him at exhibition openings
at the Museum of Modern Art. He's also currently
the Dean of the Art School at Yale and I saw
him most recently at an open studio for a
long time MoMA art handler so these are the
guys who take the painting out of the crate
and put it on the wall and Rob Storr is the
kind of guy who shows up to see their art
so I trust him personally. I think he is incredibly
intelligent and a very decent man, but personal
trust is a little bit of a straw man when
you're talking about an art museum. It's like
saying you trust the government because your
best friend from high school happens to be
the President, and what you're really striving
for is a sense of institutional trust. So
the chapter kind of goes on to describe the
time of the founding fathers as a golden age
of innovation, not in the Fine Arts directly
but in the exceptionally creative act of fashioning
a constitutional government from scratch.
I'll just - [laughs in audience]. I think
everyone here can, however restily, remember
sixth grade civics class where you studied
that in fact there's a separation of powers
so this is obviously how our American democracy
is structured but there are a lot of other
things that have a similar separation of powers.
It's the same way that back office accounting
teams and third party auditors are separate
from traders or how in the case of a film
you might have separate screenwriters, directors,
and editors. That can definitely work magnificently
but you might also end up watching an actor,
director, editor, writer whose on screen girlfriend
laughs at all his jokes and is 20 years his
junior. This is a bit unfair. So the thesis
here is that in relation to this larger definition
of art that I went through before with the
visual thinking and imagination and creativity,
museums have a capacity to be an insulated
judiciary, a bit the same way that the Supreme
Court is separate. Everyone here runs museums
wears black but not the same kind of outfits
and what I'm really trying to say is that
museums can function a lot the way libraries
do. This is an old fashioned and radical way
of thinking because a lot of people, like
myself who have MBA's, go work in museums
and apply business thinking to the management
of nonprofit organizations. Nonprofits by
definition are market failures. There is some
reason that we believe they should exist apart
from their making money directly by virtue
of their activities. They make money through
donations and foundation support and other
means so the bottom line is that museums will
- they compete with leisure activities for
peoples' time but they'll never compete apples
to apples with cinema or shopping or anything
else and then in fact, the only difference
between what they do and what libraries do
is that book are by nature private goods economically
and paintings are by nature public goods so
if you put together an exhibition, many people
can enjoy it at the same time and it's a high
fixed cost activity but very few people try
to read lots and lots of books at the same
time. One person's enjoyment of a book takes
away from another person's enjoyment so people
use them one at a time. So what I'm trying
to say is that we can embrace this public
role of museums circa The Museum of Modern
Art and the fire and people feeling this desire
to give money to it as opposed to the current
state of those institutions. MoMA was among
the ones in 2000 that had huge architectural
expansions and when they opened in 2004, they
increased the admissions charge 67% to be
twenty dollars. There is an artist who suggested
people bring the twenty dollars in pennies
which would weigh about twelve and a half
pounds but there's a trend where things that
start as creative projects then become public
and then once they're public, there's an inertia
toward becoming commercialized and there's
this active creative reinvention that has
to happen so you go back to this first stage
of recreating in order to maintain one's self
as a public institution and I think this is
the same thing that happens to successful
artists and to successful companies as well.
The market would encourage you to keep producing
the same thing, essentially becoming a branded
commodity product as opposed to constantly
reinvent so you can imagine that U2 has a
successful first or second album and that
they're pressured by record producers to continually
produce work that sounds the same, or artists
to produce work that looks the same so that
it's recognizable on an art market and that
the trick is to kind of maintain a liveliness
of an existing institution and that's no easy
to do so I'll just read a bit of the conclusion
of this chapter. The insulated judiciary is
not something we can do without because it
alone is what creates a sense of trust in
museums. If trust erodes, superficial spectacle
can intercede as an attempt to shore up the
institution when the underlying substance
has gone awry. And the pursuit of spectacle
for its own sake damages the credibility of
museums and hampers, in a boy who cried wolf
way, the pleasures of spectacle when it arises
naturally on its own, for example, when the
winner of the Tate’s Turner Prize is genuinely
and wholeheartedly a married cross dresser
in a taffeta baby doll dress elaborately embroidered
with a miniature penis motif. This is a vase
by the artist in question, Grayson Perry.
This is Grayson Perry dressed up with
his wife and child. Here he is with his art;
here he is making his art. I don't think he's
trying. I don't think the spectacle in this
case is like a sugar high. I think it's integral
to his work and there's a need to protect
that. A market favors spectacle because it
brings people in like a flash of light but
ultimately it kind of cheapens the experience
that everyone has. This is a picture of Alfred
Barr at the end of his career and I'll just
read a quotation from Nicholas Serota, the
director of the Tate, but I think it applies
to Barr's life and to the art. "Essentially
this is a plea for patience, that your skepticism
will gradually diminish, and your fear will
turn to love. All art was modern once." So
if I can just go from this sort of critique
of museums to a little bit more of what I
hope happens with them; the metaphor in the
book for how museums are in relation to the
leisure industry is that if you're trying
to compete apples to apples with film or anything
of that ilk, it's a bit like watching little
kids on the soccer field where everyone goes
to where the ball is because that's where
the excitement is instead of staying open
for a pass. I also think if museums are planning
to expand architecturally, they can have more
space for people to make art. I would love
for more people to feel invited, not just
to participate in a conversation around art,
but to identify with the artist's whose work
is in museums and some practical knowledge
of making work is important. The same way
that playing a musical instrument makes it
more interesting to listen to music. I think
you can understand the architecture of something
by trying to do it, even at the most basic
level so I'm a huge proponent of everyone
having an opportunity to be an artist. So
I'll just read a little bit more from the
epilogue of the book and there's no spoiler
here and then I'll open it up to questions.
I started to write this book because I wanted
to figure out why museums bore my friends,
at the same time that visual thinking, a main
attribute of art, is omnipresent. This question
is a subset of a larger, more philosophical
one that only yields to an indirect approach:
What is art, and how do people have it in
their lives? As I write, I am sitting in La
Rhumerie in Paris, where a friend suggested
coming for “hot milky things” but which
I have learned upon sitting down is actually
La Rhumerie as in rum. To my left, two elegant,
slightly older women fold in on their table
in conversation. To my right, glamorous Parisians
banter in wicker chairs. We are surrounded
by tribal art, Caribbean music, and a generally
happy, almost
transporting feeling. It would be possible
to hang out in a place like this your whole
life and never go to a museum and have a lively
and creative sense of the world. And that
kind of awareness is, to me, either the definition
of art or art’s more basic reason for being.
But Paris being an art capital and myself
being a museum person, I went out in the afternoon
to the Musee d’Orsay, the converted train
station where a disproportionate number of
the world’s great Impressionist paintings
live. Upon arrival I trundled down the main
atrium to Edouard Manet’s massive canvas
Le Dejeuner sur l’herbe. I was lost in thought
looking at the painting from point blank range
when a young woman tapped me on the shoulder.
Holding a camera in one hand, she asked me,
in the less polite verb form, to get out of
the way so that she could take a photograph.
I obliged, wondering why she didn't just buy
a postcard. Did she want to see the painting
or to have a record of it for later? She called
to mind a line from an Italo Calvino short
story from 1955, “The Adventures of a Photographer”:
“It is only when they have the photos before
their eyes that they seem to take tangible
possession of the day they spent. The rest
can drown in the unreliable shadow of memory.”
The only concrete definition of art I have
ever encountered was written by lawyers working
for shipping and insurance companies, clauses
about originality, read: irreplaceability,
as pertains to decorative objects that hang
on walls. At that particular point in time,
art was what Federal Express would ship internationally
but UPS would not. The German philosopher
Martin Heidegger wrote that a work of art
is that which not only creates
something new but creates the new world in
which that thing can exist. By that definition,
the change in fundamental structure of global
warfare after 9/11 and the world’s response
would both qualify as art: a new thing that
changes the world to make room for itself.
The question becomes: Is inventive national
security policy art? Michelangelo did, after
all, build defense walls in addition to painting
the ceiling of the Sistine Chapel. The rebuttal
comes from Bob, a proprietor of a used furniture
store that used to have a charming sign; “We're
cheaper than we look”; who eyed me once
and said, “You're not going to tell me everything’s
art. That cabinet is art. Legislation is art.”
Well, actually, Bob, I am. It’s not that
everything is art but that it could be. So
with that, I'll close and happily take any
questions from the audience.
[pause]
Yes?
>> So I share from my experience that audio
guides can be a very good tool to enrich my
experience and art dealer, I do lots of kind
so all that will help. I also noticed only
like a very few people at Google use it. That
may be because it's easier thing to send out
initial price so I'm wondering if you know
or would enrich a viewer's experience or is
it something that we should learn?
Amy Whitaker: Right. So you're asking about
people's experience of audio guides and the
economics. Yeah, so this is a really interesting
question of how people have complementary
information. There's a chapter in the book
called the "Revenge of the Homunculus". Claire
is actually in it. It's about that word appearing
in a wall label and about this whole question
of how museums talk to visitors. So there
is a lot of innovation happening at the moment
in that field. The North Carolina Museum of
Art is opening a new building in the Spring
and they've very consciously gotten their
most senior curators to record audio guides
that sound conversational, as if you were
just walking around with a person. Other museums
are figuring out how to have it be more casual
so to be a number that you can punch in on
your cell phones so that you don't have to
pay such a steep price and I think - what
I hear from people a lot is that they really
need that information, especially in the case
of modern art but that what's more compelling
than someone saying how important a work is,
is someone telling you the story of the artist
so you can relate to this person who actually
made something and was compelled for a reason,
whether economic or a need to create a work
of art. It's kind of what happened from the
blank canvas point of view so I would agree
with you that the economics are off and I
think what happens in a lot of other media
industries may happen to audio guides where
people realize how cheap the underlying technology
is and either try to produce it in house,
which a lot of museums do, or it gets priced
out or - I don't want to say pirated because
I don't think that that would exactly - there's
too much research required. I personally think
it would also be wonderful if, when you bought
your tickets to go to a museum exhibition
or when you planned to, you could go on the
website ahead of time, the way that you print
a boarding pass to take a plane flight, and
you could print the material and take it with
you so that you don't have to walk over to
the wall and read the label. There's a passage
in "Revenge of the Homunculus" about a reporter
who clocked people in exhibitions to see how
long they looked at the art and they spent
50 seconds reading the wall label and 4 seconds
looking at the art. But I think you're kind
of getting at this underlying issue of open
ended curiosity in looking at art and trying
to understand the importance of something
and to appreciate it. Appreciation is more
in the mode of an art historian or a critics
point of view and open ended curiosity is
more identifying with the artist. Yes?
>> I get your point about people experiencing
art because as reading, we have the inability
class that we can transport into our class.
We know how successful that was. Are there
any existing example you have of that, where
museums might be willing to create art as
engagement?
Amy Whitaker: Well I think a lot of - so this
is a question about - I'm supposed to repeat
the questions for the benefit of anyone watching
this later. I can hear you loud and clear.
This is a questions about whether there are
any good examples of museums currently bringing
people in to feel a sense of creative ownership
and making work in the gallery. There's a
story in the book in a chapter called "On
Boredom" about a group of miners in the north
of England who started making their own art.
It's one of my favorite stories in the book.
So yes, there are a lot of museums who have
interesting art making activities. Most of
them tend to be geared toward children and
they do have art making classes for adults
and at one point I looked at the offerings
of the Museum of Modern Art and all of the
studio classes were sold out well ahead of
time, granted there were fewer of them, so
I think there's an appetite. One of the things
that I've really been looking at is the way
in which people interact with art outside
of museums. For example, there's a company
in the outskirts of Philadelphia called SEI
Investments that has a world class collection
of contemporary art so people live near it
and they have open plan work spaces. All the
desks are on wheels and there are power cables
that come out of the ceiling every so often
and literally someone will work next to a
life size handsewn Hummer or a wall covered
in fiber glass poisonous mushrooms or a pair
of men's wing tip shoes that are made out
licorice and are three feet tall so I think
that there's this question of kind of art
in everyday life but I think there's a real
dearth of opportunity for people to make work
and I've given a related talk in a corporate
setting and had people draw and you can feel
the energy in the room change when people
are given a marker and asked to look at each
other and draw without staring at their paper
so I'd like to see more of it. If I had one
recommendation from the book, it would be
the importance of studio art, not just to
museums but to people's overall lives. Yes?
>> So you talk about giving us the answers
to insulated judiciary. How can museums balance
- I guess how can they keep themselves from
turning into insulated in a way? And maintain
that cycle of innovation, even from just saying
good art and all the things we have, that's
what art is, you know?
Amy Whitaker: So this is a very related question
about how museums keep themselves from becoming
overly insulated to a elite judiciary and
it's a political structural question and the
answer has everything to do with more people
making art. So for me, if you describe museums
as a judiciary, then they're a political institution
and all political institutions in a democracy
exist in relation to a notion of citizenship
so what I would say is that the idea of being
a citizen of the art world is to be an artist
oneself, not just to be an appreciator of
art. So I would invite more and more people
into the conversation around art and into
the public debate around the role of museums
and art and society and I think therefore
you get this countervailing force. You get
an insulated judiciary on the one hand and
then you also get what the same founding fathers
would have called "factions" on the other,
this colliding molecules view of a lot of
viewpoints and I think we don't have that
now because there are a lot of exceptionally
smart, curious, creative people who apply
these first principles of art in other areas
but without it being connected to art as a
discipline. I mean, art is as basic as writing
or math as a mode of communication but it's
also interpreted as a rarefied disciplinary
area so exactly to your point. I think if
more people participated in the conversation
that would counteract that worry.
>> So I was wondering if you'd talk a little
bit more about museums focused on like the
big ticket items like the blockbusters versus
like continuing with their educational mission
and one example that comes to mind is the
DeGross Clinic meaning that it was in like
a hospital in Philadelphia and this famous
painting, they were going to sell it to Arkansas
but then the city banded together to raise
money and it was a big rallying cry but that's
just one painting that you'll see in one room.
How do they like band together and traffic
in other areas?
Amy Whitaker: Yeah. So this is a really interesting
questions of museums focusing their attention
on blockbuster exhibitions and on single famous
iconic paintings and how to get people to
put their attention elsewhere. Is that fair,
Cliff? So I thin part of this is just basic
human psychology that people like to respond
to a crisis or go see a particular thing.
I think museums are suffering in a way. They're
really struggling to figure out how to appeal
to a broad audience and they think that one
of the ways to do that is to have these masterpieces
and these big exhibitions. There are a couple
of quotations that I didn't read from the
book about all the banners furling and unfurling
in front of a museum as not a flush of health
but a flush of fever and I think that you're
exactly right. My feeling is that if museums
- it's a chicken, egg problem but if they
stopped having blockbuster exhibitions and
they stopped feeling this need constantly
to expand, which is a function of donors being
excited by a concrete project or needing to
call us, the momentum of staff around something
tangible. If people could wean themselves
off of that temporarily and turn scholarly
attention to their own permanent collections
and create real information about other works
of art, and if you didn't have to pay so much
to go to a museum so it wasn't structured
like an all you can eat buffet economically,
you could champion the drop in visit and someone
could go - really feel invited to look at
any work of art that appealed to them and
kind of have it 'normed' that looking at one
thing or three things before you leave is
totally reasonable, much more perfume counter,
much less all you can eat buffet so I think
that what happens is that there's not a lot
of information about other works in the collection
because they spend so much time constantly
hustling to get exhibitions off the ground
and they pay a lot of money for some of them
too. It'll cost a million dollars to bring
in a traveling show, just the fee to the organizing
institution so I think a lot of that is just
psychology. The notion of betterment as opposed
to the notion of growth and I would love to
see it happen. The only other thing I would
suggest along those lines is there's some
museums that justify expanding architecturally
because they have so many wonderful works
in storage but what I think would actually
be great is if they are only showing the top
five or ten percent of their collection, if
they took the next fifteen or twenty percent
and sent it on a semi-permanent loan to regional
museums then I think there would be many,
many more works of art for people to go look
at because often you get this dynamic of a
big blockbuster show coming to a regional
city because they have work in their collection
by major artists but it might be third rate
work and therefore they talk about it in terms
of the importance of the artist overall and
not just in terms of the actual work of art.
But I would love to see more of that happen.
>> Are there any efforts in the way of
Amy Whitaker: So Pepe is asking if there are
projects to create more virtual museums online.
Yes, absolutely, very much so. A lot of museums,
I think, see it as a chance to have a scholarly
database to - they have a lot of material
that's geared toward teachers. The Metropolitan,
the Museum of Modern Art, the Tate, a lot
of the big museums have exceptionally good
databases. I don't think that so many of them
have organized them as virtual tours because
there's this whole question of the importance
of seeing an original work of art. This is
the same as the question of finding enough
places to sit. If you didn't believe in the
original work of art, museums could project
up enormous copies of things and have tons
of seats in the middle and everybody could
see well enough so I think they currently
see it as a compliment to and not a substitute
for the work of art but that's changed over
time. If you had asked that question in 2000,
2001, there was tremendous excitement around
monetizing their collections in that fashion,
to cross subsidize other activities.
>> I had one other question. Are there things
that the art museum world can learn from like
science museums and like the science industry
and things like that?
Amy Whitaker: Yeah, that's a really interesting
question. How much art museums can learn from
science and industry museums. I think art
museums - there's something that's always
a little bit subjective about them so if anything
they grow out a tradition of science museums
because the earliest instances of
museums were scholarly cabinets of curiosity
or what are essentially libraries so they
were taxonomic and I think that comes directly
from science museums and if anything I think
art museums are experimenting with growing
away from that tradition and embracing subjectivity
more so. One of my favorite formats of exhibition
is called "Label Talk" where the Williams
College Museum of Art does this under that
name, a few other museums do it otherwise
where they invite lots of people to come in
and write essays about the same work of art
so instead of a single "this is the scientific
truth of this painting", you'll have three
or four labels. Say it's a picture of George
Washington; there'll be a historian, there'll
be an artist, there'll be a scientist talking
about how they would look at the painting
so I think, if anything, they're growing away
from it a little bit. Is there - we have time
for one more question or we can go ahead and
wrap up. Yes?
>> Along the same concept ,is there like an
increase
Amy Whitaker: Mm hmm. So there's this question
of increased interactivity in museum exhibitions.
I think absolutely they do have that. There
are a lot more computers in the galleries
and there aren't quite a number of companies
that do exhibition design that focus on those
kind of whistles and bell. In my opinion,
and I'm very old fashioned this way, I prefer
just to be able to sit in front of a work
of art and for the work of art to speak on
its own. A bench is an invitation to sit and
to have information as much as I want but
the ways in which I've most enjoyed seeing
computers used is to further a conversation
so there'll be computers where people can
log anonymous comments that are then posted
on the wall of the exhibition so they are
used to create a framework for a conversation
more so then this kind of whistle and bell.
I think this is the kind of last side of - you
know, if you take a Van Gogh painting and
you shine a strobe light on it, it doesn't
become this. [laughs from audience] And I
think the same thing is true of having computers
in the galleries. There's so much contemporary
work that's made in that way and absolutely
if the work is made out of computers, technology
is integral but I think there are natural
limitations to feeling that putting a kiosk,
you know, with Van Gogh activities for children
next to a Van Gogh painting, that can be great
but I don't think it's necessarily an end
all be all. I think having simply a piece
of paper and a pen is often the most revolutionary
way of interacting that you can have. So I'll
just close again by saying thank you so much
for having me here. I'm very honored and I
care a lot about people's relationship to
museums but that's really because I care about
museums relationship to how people think as
they're walking down the street on any given
Tuesday so I hope you embrace your own creative
projects at work or otherwise and that that
helps you enjoy museums and that museums help
you enjoy those things so thanks again very
much and I'll leave it there. [applause from
audience]